hey guys I was so excited cuz today
we're about to go on a helicopter ride
with Bradley and his dog Bentley
now Bentley has been riding around on
the helicopter with Bradley for quite a
while you may have seen him on Instagram
or YouTube or somewhere on the internet
but today Jenna and Suzy and I are going
to ride with Bentley
we got Bentley a present I hope that he
likes it I think you will its
cheeseburger he likes us
that's important very important I don't
care what anyone else thinks and makes
up that way this is not just you need
sir cheeseburger boy so one of his
favorites is Brussels sprouts
that's weird Emily loves raw Brussels
sprouts
then the findings like fennel that's
true he could like literally just pitch
Bentley you wouldn't go on a ride a
helicopter okay bye-bye
he only listens to his owner he's like
nope Bradley's going this way I'm going
this way so here's the helicopter about
to head up I'm not actually sure where
we're going it didn't even ask I just
basically said cool worm you want to
take us we're ready for an adventure
[Music]
so you have your entire helicopter
basically are tricked out for making
video tricked out like it's crazy you
even have a dongles that you can make
Instagram strangles double double double
dongle not a GoPro got the headsets not
a GoPro so how long you been flying been
doing a lot of makes up flight simulator
and stuff so I'm getting really really
good at it
I'm still a little wobbly so I'm really
excited to try this out and realize my
parents are gonna be terrified 27 years
ago
27:27 yeah that's weird I'm like 29 and
now isn't flying for 27 this is it's
magic
[Music]
okay we're about to take off where are
we going today we're going into the
mountains okay cool
I didn't even ask those like let's just
go you know getting into helicopters
with strangers and you're getting into
cars with strangers I mean you know we
met one yeah this is called widget Creek
oh yeah so widget Lake can land on the
rocket widget other nature's helipad we
call it the only places you're not
supposed to land or is it just safe
around here there's really nowhere that
I'm not allowed to land like private
property obviously I've had property
rules apply built-up areas so if there's
like like a community and then there's a
park north of here called Garibaldi
that's prohibited for aircraft movement
people land there I'm the only guy that
I know that's ever landed here so I had
to go in first drop two guys that had to
move all the rock stuff so I could
actually get back in right now we're
doing 70 knots and almost same on the
ground so we're doing about 80 miles an
hour
oh wow I won't leave it flying Elliot's
just going with me since it's a big 2015
I only say he has about 250 hours all
right you guys want to hear cameras up
oh yeah oh my gosh it's so pretty
this one campers down on the left down
there oh great
[Music]
oh my god no I view these things with my
drone and it's not nation Oh
[Music]
we're gonna pick this is awesome oh my
gosh this is crazy
I'm having the best time
so he just made our first stop Bentley
is out and ceiling sticks it's
absolutely so beautiful and we only flew
for 15 minutes to get here where would
you like region pinecone / Burt
Provincial Park or do you want snow
should we go get some snow we've landed
before and he's got out of the
helicopter and peed for a minute and a
half straight hit but he won't pee on
snow because snow smooth
[Music]
[Applause]
- my favorite scene from Star Wars but
things like really wrong
whoa oh my god
[Music]
that cool is so cool
all right let's head down to the Pitt
River hostage
[Music]
Wow we're landing on the bridge oh my
goodness I'm proud when I land my drone
on like a small little rock so you're at
our next destination where are we now
Pitt River Hot Springs so probably the
nicest hot springs on albey Syria there
it's so pretty I'm gonna try to fly my
drone through here it's a little bit
windy so hopefully all goes well flying
a drone flying a helicopter two very
different things
[Music]
Wow look at that guy so see these lines
in the ice those're every year so you
can wrinkle to the tree this is really
defined life
those are like a wrinkle to a tree for
snowpack I think melt snow pack it melt
[Music]
we are now going to some ice caves
Bentley loves snow so much and he's got
on those little jackets and here we go
we're going in it's absolutely just
stunning this view I've also got my
insta 361 cameras and they get some 360
shots and see we can get you guys ready
Oh
hi Bentley look at you buddy
oh look somebody's camping that's right
that's pretty amazing that they have
survival gear just in case of an
emergency
camera
no like I'm touching it but in the
camera doesn't look like it
this is so freaking ball guy this is so
incredible like I'm freaking out
[Music]
aha
definitely have a wet foot waterproof
lies
[Music]
we're obligations now we're heading back
into the helicopter and we're heading
back out this was so awesome
[Applause]
you hear me crunching oh man you guys
are missing out
Wow we touched that water is that we
touched that water that water touch NASA
definitely it touch my foot that's it's
still touching it
oh my feet oh yeah they're full wow wow
wow
ROK's best amusement park right yeah
it's I mean I don't really know if it's
close to it this is like the sort
through California
[Applause]
[Music]
well guys we've officially landed you so
much this is an official way this is an
official landing we're here we're back
I'm exhausted and we didn't even do it
right sitting in your seat is hard
Sunday wow this is so great incredible
experience
Bentley hi baby he's been so sweet back
here
Bentley oh he's so hyped about the
Brussels sprouts so great well that
brings today to a close we had so much
fun with Bentley so much fun with
Bradley
I have never spent that much time in a
helicopter before and it was probably
one of the best experiences ever I'll
see you guys my next video bye
[Music]